e eu não falei muito cedo e ele 21 anos
fui delegados de polícia para
conhecê-los asco delegacia de defesa da
mulher neste trabalho na delegacia sobre
o caso de uma menina de 12 anos de idade
que tinha sido estuprada pelo pai
é o caso da trazendo pela professora que
é bastante comum normalmente casos de
violência doméstica graves de violência
sexuais muitas vezes chegam por meio da
escola e a professora levou este casa
para nós
se você configurou super imaginar teu um
bicho lá no segredo naquele momento na
delegacia é pensando nessa coisa medonha
com essa menina chama os estamos sujeito
eu só vou se ferrar dá uma bronca
gigante falar com a minha indignação e
ao final da minha sala ele olhou com
tranquilidade e fala o jeito dele de
dizer não é uma linguagem dele ele me
disse alguma coisa do tipo não tô
entendendo o que eu que fiz não vamos ah
eu tenho direito de usar primeiro
e é lógico que naquele momento com 21
anos chegando na delegacia o realmente
não entendi essa fala de forma nenhuma
depois de uma longa estrada de ouvir
muita expressão de que o primeiro fruto
da bananeira tem comi foi quem implantou
eu entendi que esse homem pediu um
contexto de permissividade desta
violência o que ele não estava sozinho
mas que espera uma cultura permissiva
desta violência possa história que eu tô
contando é uma história que pelo código
penal se configura como estupro de
vulnerável e que a sociedade enxerga
como abuso abuso sexual abuso de criança
todas façam pai padrasto quando você tá
assistindo o jornal e passa aquela
notícia de que a criança de 6 anos foi
estuprado por favor e que inspiram
estômago
se você não consegue nem comer depois
disso né é muito uma coisa depois eu só
sensação tão ruim e qualquer um de
inocente a gente não sai aí com essa
bandeira de vamos fazer qualquer coisa
para isso não acontecer mais
e eu acho que a gente não sai por duas
casa dizer que são fala depois sobre
esse assunto do razões a gente não não
faz a primeira até um assunto muito duro
é muito duro falar sobre violência
sexual contra crianças e adolescentes é
muito duro falar disso proficiência e a
gente não gosta de falar do que é muito
durga muito sofrido para nós a segunda
questão e que eu acho que é mais
importante para nós aqui aqui no fundo
fica no imaginário da sociedade que
aquela pessoa um monstro que atacou uma
criança e virou notícia policial e
aquilo parece uma coisa excepcional
caderno que é tão curioso que parece
excepcional
é só que não é
e os números do último boletim do
ministério da saúde sobre a questão de
2018 dão para a gente a noção de que
mais ou menos 55 crianças são estupradas
todo dia no brasil ruína é uma notícia e
agora já não 55 de repente então quando
a gente olha onde vêm essas notícias e
sessenta por cento dessas notificações
vem da região sul e sudeste vocês
calculam há imensas subnotificação então
nós estamos falando de um crime é um
crime muito mais a pesado e numeroso do
que a gente encontra nos dados a gente
sabe que mesmo em são paulo isso
notificado muito bem mas esse essa
situação do suco de vulnerável tem uma
outra situação de violência sexual que é
muito séria e à exploração sexual de
crianças e
e agora vou explicar para vocês o que
que é um crime previsto no código penal
até dez anos de cadeia o que é a
exploração sexual sabe aquela menina que
você ouviu a notícia no jornal pois é
oito anos depois você tá andando na
praia e você encontra uma menina de pote
só pezinho aqui no terminal de cargas
fernão dias no ceagesp né sim insinuando
para alguns homens homens mais velhos
você vai passar na calçada na praia
talvez você veja essa situação mas
talvez você nem veja a situação porque
nós não estamos com olhos treinados para
enxergar essa situação nos enxergar o
que você vai sentir maioria das pessoas
sente que absurdo
é mas ninguém vai tentar vir na sua
seção ou vai chamar a polícia para ver o
que está acontecendo e isso tá
acontecendo aqui é exploração sexual de
crianças e adolescentes que é
popularmente conhecida como prostituição
infantil e aqui a gente não fala sobre
estrangeiros para o brasil turismo
conhecido como sexual está falando que
acontece no brasil inteiro em todos os
mas se a gente não vê a gente não tá
treinando a gente não tem no olhar para
ele se não terminou porque porque nós
somos uma sociedade extremamente
machista que culpabiliza a mulher pela
violência que ela está submetida e
contabiliza a menina
e esta é a razão pela qual nós não vemos
a você não você tá exagerando não não tô
exagerando
e nós encomendamos uma pesquisa com o
datafolha em 2018 para entender para
percepção do brasil sobre exploração
sexual isso porque porque nós somos o
segundo país com maior índice de
prostituição infantil fala o graças não
é porque a criança não se prostitui ela
explorar mas é conhecido como
prostituição infantil eu sou o segundo
país como ninguém fala disso a gente se
junta numa mesa vá para falar de
problema de saúde problema de educação a
gente fala de programa político como é
que fala de legalização do aborto
legalização da droga mas a gente não
fala sobre violência sexual contra
crianças e adolescentes muito menos
sobre exploração sexual nós somos o
segundo país com maior índice de
exploração sexual muito bem
eu não tô falando então não há cultura é
uma cultura extremamente machista também
racista sabe que o recorte aqui era da
exploração meninos e meninas estão
sujeitos à violência sexual mas existe
um recorte assim muito forte de gênero e
raça a maioria meninas e a maioria
meninas negras neste contexto de cultura
machista a gente pensa é uma cultura
antiga e a gente vai lutando com isso né
eu lembro sempre da questão da violência
contra a mulher quando eu era a delegada
em osasco 30 anos atrás tinha a lei
maria da penha a máxima briga de marido
e mulher ninguém mete a colher era
máxima que integrada
há 30 anos depois a violência contra
mulher contém uma série cima mas ninguém
mais tem coragem de dizer não é para
meter a colher a imprensa fala de sempre
ter as empresas querem se engajar com
essa causa é legal falar e se engajar
nessa questão poder público pensa
políticas para resolver essa questão é
tudo porque porque começou uma onda a
sociedade começou a falar essa questão
indignada essa violência a gente fala
bom violência contra criança e
adolescente próximas isso vai acontecer
a mesma coisa
ah entendi há 2 anos atrás eu descobri
que a gente não tava brigando só uma
cultura antiga a gente está brigando
contra um poder econômico forte no
poderosíssimo que tem retroalimentado
essa violência de forma ainda mais
perversa e que a indústria da
pornografia
a indústria da pornografia ela concorre
hoje em valores um álcool e tabaco
álcool e tabaco são duas questões
altamente regulamentada sociedade mas
ninguém fala de regulamentação de
tomografia por que então tabu tá bom
você não mas o que que é o grafia tem a
ver com violência contra criança e
adolescente você sabe que o termo mais
procurado em sites pornográficos no
mundo é tipo o que a gente pode produzir
mais sexo adolescente para nossa novinha
aqui no brasil ou seja a esta
alimentação e sem incentivo de sexo com
meninas novinhas é muito forte é muito
forte mas isso não é problema o problema
é quando você abre um site pornográfico
e eu sugiro que vocês têm que eu tô
falando que não conhece
e eu não tô fazendo aqui de ti web eu
não tô falando é de pornografia infantil
que é uma outra questão eu tô falando
site pago com cartão de crédito e se
você abrir para encontrar vários filmes
aberto cyrus não precisa colocar o seu
cartão de crédito os seguintes títulos
se operando sobrinha padrasto arrumando
enteada filha se divertindo com o pai é
bom então atores não são estou sem reais
e aquelas meninas
e são maiores de 18 anos não são menores
a história pode quando sociedade
permitir isto eu digo isso porque nós
somos uma sociedade que já conquistamos
por exemplo uma decisão do supremo
tribunal federal dizendo que um editor
que publicar um livro faz apologia ao
nazismo não pode pode não pode mesmo
porque uma sociedade que é comprometida
com os direitos humanos é comprometida
com a dignidade da pessoa humana não
pode aceitar certos comportamentos
bom então nós não podemos aceitar pela
região pode aceitar vai se planta sofia
num site aberto a gente quiser repensar
o quê que isso não tem importância isso
não tem importância porque a gente não
enxerga essa violência quem abre o site
pornográfico vesti nome e não reaja isso
essa é a mesma pessoa que não está
reagindo quando vi a menina na praia ou
aqui na estação de cargas fernão dias
não reagir porque não ver e não ver
porque não tem importância não tem
importância porque ela está lá porque
ela quer enquanto a gente não olhar para
ir 50 sociedade não tem solução porque
se não é um problema pensando nisso o
estudo liberta que eu trazido um
parceria com o instituto alana uma
produção de maria farinha lançamos este
essa semana um documentário chamado um
clima entre nós documentário eu espero
que todos assistam é importantíssimo vai
desnaturalizar um pouco essa violência
que tá tão arraigada na nossa sociedade
porque na hora que cai a ficha
importância de falar sobre custo social
o pessoal diz não falar sobre isso eu
acho que essa é uma onda a gente tem que
entrar nessa onda e como teve a onda da
violência contra mulher a discussão a
indignação a gente vai fazer o brasil
entrar nessa onda cara não dá mais para
aceitar violência sexual contra crianças
e adolescentes não dá
e a gente espera que o documentário
ajude a violência sexual contra crianças
e adolescentes ser um problema no brasil
problema de julgar eu tenho quantos não
foram problemas não vai ter solução é